quanti in sala pensano che i rifiuti
siano uno dei maggiori problemi nelle
grandi città molti sono convinti che la
colpa sia del sistema
oggi sono qui per mostrarvi cosa
possiamo fare noi per cambiare questo
sistema e per parlarvi di zero waste
zero rifiuti e zero sprechi
il mio marito siamo due biologi marini
per anni abbiamo studiato la
biodiversità l'inquinamento l'impatto
dell'uomo sull'ambiente
siamo sempre ritenuti una famiglia
ecologica amo pochissimo o per niente la
macchina facevamo la raccolta
differenziata seguendo tutte le regole
quando però siamo arrivati a napoli
abbiamo capito che stavamo sbagliando
qualcosa
la sera infatti durante il nostro
trasloco tornando da uno degli
innumerevoli viaggi ai cassonetti della
spazzatura per buttare tutti gli
imballaggi
mi sono resa conto che non stiamo
facendo proprio niente per proteggere
l'ambiente con l'uso di tutta quella
plastica usa e getta stavamo invece
creando un mini disastro ambientale
inoltre criticavo l'enorme quantità di
spazzatura che vedevo per le strade di
napoli ma non stavo facendo niente per
ridurla
l'unica differenza era che la nostra
spazzatura era divisa per categoria
la notte ha dormito pochissimo
ho passato ore su internet a cercare di
capire cosa potevo fare io cosa poteva
fare la mia famiglia per ridurre i
rifiuti
ho scoperto che ci sono persone che in
un anno producono così pochi rifiuti da
poter essere contenuti in un barattolo
di marmellata o meno 500 grammi compreso
il barattolo volete sapere qual è la
media nazionale
in un anno un italiano produce in media
500 kg di rifiuti hi lo e mezzo al
giorno
la bella differenza no
ho capito che dovevamo fare qualcosa
dovevamo cambiare il nostro
comportamento
se volevamo evitare di produrre quella
spazzatura
altrimenti come avremmo potuto definirci
ancora amanti dell'ambiente sarà vamo
noi i primi a contribuire alle montagne
di rifiuti che si accumulano nei nostri
mari
perché mentre noi compriamo verdura
imballata singolarmente beviamo acqua
dalla bottiglietta in plastica usa e
getta
obbediamo il caffè dal bicchierino
monouso le plastiche le micro e le
microplastiche invadono i nostri mari e
non sto parlando del mare dell'oceano
pacifico delle isole di plastica in
pacifico che forse avete visto in tv no
sto parlando del nostro mare il mar
mediterraneo
cosa sono le micro plastiche le micro
plastiche sono tutti quei pezzettini di
plastica che derivano da cosmetici
vestiti materiale plastico più grande
che si frammenta e pezzettini via via
sempre più piccoli fino ad arrivare a 5
mm di diametro molti materiali infatti
non si degradano rimangono nell'ambiente
per centinaia di anni in frammenti
appunto via via sempre più piccoli e
possono creare dei disastri ambientali
di portata inimmaginabile il
mediterraneo le microplastiche arrivano
fino a 10 kg per chilometro quadrato
praticamente una zuppa di plastica io
non ci nuoterebbe e immagino neanche voi
e così abbiamo invertito la rotta
abbiamo iniziato ad adottare uno stile
di vita zero waste cosa vuol dire zero
waste letteralmente dall'inglese zero
waste senza zero sprechi e zero rifiuti
si tratta di uno stile di vita che punta
a minimizzare o anzi ad eliminare i
rifiuti che devono essere mandati in
discarica ea minimizzare
lì che possono essere riciclati si
tratta di uno stile di vita più
sostenibile più semplice e per certi
versi anche più lento arrivare a zero
rifiuti può sembrare un obiettivo
irraggiungibile l'importante però non è
focalizzarsi sullo zero ma impegnarsi
ogni giorno a fare del proprio meglio
per ridurli
ci sono diversi approcci allo zero
rifiuti e sono convinta che ogni persona
ogni famiglia dovrebbe trovare il suo
ricordiamoci però sempre che basta anche
un solo piccolo gesto ma fatto da
tantissime persone per fare una grande
differenza ed avere un grande impatto
sugli altri dopo due anni ancora
facciamo i nostri viaggi al cassonetto e
la spazzatura ma una sola volta a
settimana per l'organico è una volta al
mese o anche meno per tutto il resto ho
un blog vivere senza rifiuti in cui
racconto la mia storia di zero waste era
a napoli e cerchiamo ogni giorno di fare
scelte migliori per noi e per l'ambiente
il nostro primo passo è stato analizzare
cosa c'era nella nostra spazzatura
il secondo è stato quello di trovare
alternative durevoli a quelle usa e
getta
un passo alla volta ma tutto questo
doveva essere sostenibile anche da un
punto di vista economico
quando siamo arrivati io ero senza
lavoro avevamo appena affrontato un
trasloco internazionale e iniziamo la
nostra vita in una nuova città
siamo quindi partiti da quello che per
noi era il passo più semplice quello che
ci sembrava più facile eliminare l'acqua
in bottiglia
ci siamo muniti di due borracce
riutilizzabili che riempiamo con l'acqua
del rubinetto
in un anno la nostra famiglia ha evitato
di acquistare almeno 600 bottiglie di
plastica evitando non solo la plastica
usa e getta ma risparmiando anche molti
soldi perché la l'acqua in bottiglia
costa molto di più di quella del
rubinetto
abbiamo trovato qui a napoli e
tantissime botteghe e negozi alimentari
che vendono sfuso compriamo il cibo con
i nostri sacchetti di stoffa che abbiamo
ricavato da vecchie federe o da scampoli
di stoffa che avevamo in casa
usiamo tovaglioli fazzoletti e spugne e
stoffa e abbiamo comprato i pannolini
lavabili per nostro figlio in bagno
usiamo dei saponi solidi rifiutiamo
sempre sempre la plastica usa e getta
se siamo in un bar in un locale o in un
ristorante
chiediamo di non usare la cannuccia o i
bicchieri monouso portiamo sempre con
noi la nostra borraccia per l'acqua se
andiamo a fare acquisti portiamo la
nostra borsa in cotone e se andiamo al
ristorante portiamo con noi un
contenitore per gli avanzi dobbiamo
ricordarci che acquistare è uguale a
votare votiamo con i nostri acquisti
quando stiamo comprando un prodotto
stiamo dicendo al mercato e di produrlo
proprio in quel modo perché ci piace e
di continuare a fare così scegliamo
quindi sempre molto molto attentamente a
chi dare il nostro voto
da quando abbiamo iniziato questo stile
di vita compriamo di meno ma di maggiore
qualità e la nostra prima opzione è
sempre l'usato cerchiamo di investire di
più cerchiamo di investire di meno negli
oggetti e di più nelle esperienze e
nelle relazioni con le persone
abbiamo ridotto quelli che sono soltanto
dei bisogni indotti ci siamo resi conto
che non avevamo bisogno di tutti quei
prodotti per la cura del corpo o
dell'ultimo gadget tecnologico che
potevamo semplicemente farne a meno
dopo qualche mese
passavo ancora ore e ore su internet a
cercare di capire come potevo ridurre
ancora di più i nostri rifiuti
ho iniziato anche ad autoprodurre
con qualche successo come ad esempio il
detersivo per il bucato che ora mia
madre capite mia madre una mamma del sud
mi chiede di fare per lei e vari
disastri come il dentifricio a base di
olio di cocco poi quella base di argilla
poi il dentifricio a base di bicarbonato
e poi basta adesso non lo autoproduco
più lo compro
ma in vetro on line ho incontrato donne
e ragazze che come me cercavano di
cambiare il loro stile di vita
abbiamo creato un gruppo whatsapp non
molto originale ma dopo un po il gruppo
si era fatto talmente grande eravamo
talmente tante che questo gruppo era
diventato ingestibile e abbiamo dato
vita alla rete zero waste per ispirare
questo cambiamento e per dare la
possibilità a chi si trova nella stessa
località di entrare in contatto nel
virtuale ma poi di incontrarsi nel reale
dopo un po è iniziato a succedere
intorno a me qualcosa che mai mi sarei
aspettata anche gli altri hanno iniziato
a cambiare ad esempio il cameriere del
mio bar preferito
adesso serve l'acqua in un bicchiere di
vetro anziché in plastica il panettiere
sotto casa non prepara più il sacchetto
di carta quando ci sono io perché sa che
porto il mio e stoffa e nella mensa del
mio istituto sono a parte apparse le
brocche non c'è più l'acqua
imbottigliata
il mio capo è arrivato in ufficio con i
bicchierini in vetro per sostituire
quelli usa e getta anche un solo gesto
può fare una grande differenza avere un
grande impatto
quindi perché non iniziare oggi
[Applauso]